thank you very much for being on the
program now there's been an awful lot of
pitch rolling about what to expect for
from the Autumn statements um by
watering difficult decisions according
to the chancellor do we need to brace
ourselves I think it's going to be quite
tough because what we do know very
clearly is we've got very high inflation
very tight labor market we're going to
be uh have the prospect of pretty low
growth for some time in common with
other economies around the world the IMF
is saying about a third of world
economies will go into recession in the
next year and that's the backdrop with
this huge fiscal hole that needs to be
filled so what we know from that is
they're going to be some very tough
decisions he's going to have to take on
tax and on spending what we don't know
is what exactly they're going to look
like but there is a 50 plus billion
pound fiscal hold to fill and that means
some big decisions I think and we were
going to be paying more tax the chance I
think has said that
um whether it's actually everybody down
to every last member of the public that
pays more tax or not let's wait to see
but I think the point that he's making
there is that the size of that fiscal
hole is such that you're going to
probably have to look at tax measures
that are fairly broadly based if you're
going to bring in the amounts of money
that's required and there's also of
course talk about cuts to public service
and that's going to be alarming for a
lot of people who will be looking at the
state of their public services and
thinking where is the fat to be trimmed
here schools for example you know where
they've got you know talking about
cutting teaching assistants or cutting
back on textbooks at a time when
inflation is already at 11 yes
that's part of what's going to be really
difficult now one of the first decisions
he's going to have to take is what's the
balance between tax Rises and
expenditure cut so we don't know that
yet but the more he leans into tax of
course the less he'll have to lean into
controlling expenditure well you're
absolutely right with inflation as it is
at the moment given that most spending
settlements uh were struck some time ago
when expectations of inflation were much
lower there are going to be those
additional pressures on the public
finances but let's see what he has to
say about that bear in mind of course
the pain here will probably be spread
over several years maybe five years
before we reach the critical point where
his fiscal Target kicks in which I think
will probably be 20 27 28 and it's in
that year that he has to get all these
Sons to add up it doesn't necessarily
have to go for lots of short-term pain
he could spread it you see I this is
where my it's like skepticism kicks in
I'll be honest
uh because obviously there will be some
things that come in earlier
some of these cuts and spending squeezes
a bit of a fantasy designed to reassure
the markets in the short term but in the
long term particularly the ones that as
you say are post the next election it's
not going to happen are they well I
think the critical phrase you've just
used there Sophie is reassure the
markets that's the litmus test so the
markets will have a very good news for
this they will look at the plans that
are put forward and they will say
perhaps I don't think it will happen but
maybe they might say there's too much
pain tomorrow you know it's getting too
easier ride he's pushing it all to the
back beyond the next general election it
doesn't feel credible I don't think
you'll make that mistake so I think
there will be a fairly balanced budget
in terms of what tax and spending are
doing the short and medium term as well
as as well as further down the line and
I want to talk to you a bit about your
department work and pensions at Big
spending departments uh of course now
Jamie hunt told me at the weekend we've
got a big increase in the number of
people who aren't working who aren't
taking part in work even though they
perhaps could is he right yes he's
absolutely right now as it happens
compared to other major economies they
are in a very similar position in fact
we're in no worser position than most
other economies but nonetheless there
are nine million people who are
economically inactive and they fall into
four basic groups one is students then
you've got those that have retired early
you've got those that are long-term uh
sick and you've got those that are
caring have caring responsibilities now
each one of those cohorts has different
levers if you like that you can try and
pull to encourage and support them into
work and what the Prime Minister has
asked me to do is to look at that as a
main project now for the DWP is how do
we really get across all those cohorts
and do whatever we can to make sure we
increase the uptake of those going into
the workplace particularly as that
number's grown a lot during the pandemic
and that's just 600 000 went into
economic inactivity over the period of
time so what levers are you going to
pull then to try and encourage if you
like so these people yeah so the kindest
gloss on it yes so it depends on the
group that you're looking at so for
example if they are already engaged with
the department for work and pensions
they're on benefits one would look at
for example what kind of support are we
providing people to get into work how
frequently frequent is the contact we
have for those for example that are on
Universal Credit uh how many hours do we
expect people to work before we take a
lighter touch approach to that do you
know do we extend the number of hours we
expect people to be in work before we
say right okay we can leave you uh that
support withdraw that support a little
bit so I think there are issues around
conditionality and benefits if you've
retired however early say age 55 and
you're feeling comfortable and you're
not claiming any benefits at all then
you're kind of beyond our boundary but
nonetheless there might be things that
government more generally can do to
encourage those people back into work
flexible working offers for example
making sure that those individuals are
really clear as to what the costs of
their retirement are going to be because
they're working on this assumption that
you know taking it easy at 55 is going
to still work out by the time you reach
65. so so there are all sorts of
different interventions but what I'm
going to do is look at each one of those
cohorts in detail and do the really hard
research kicking the ties to make sure
we come up with the best possible policy
so you're quite open saying that you are
going to be trying to effectively push
some people on benefits back into work
they should be working more in when the
when the Prime Minister appointed me in
the cabinet room he discussed the
various things he wanted me to do on top
of that list was economic uh uh you know
those that are disengage I mean some
will be saying that it sounds you know
could be seen as a bit heartless if you
know a lot of people that particularly
on you know long-term sake who are on or
on caring as you say or on benefits
struggling and trying to make things
work with inflation they'll be looking
at what you're saying and thinking hang
on a minute he's talking about taking my
money away from me and I cannot this is
well well this is well I'm not talking
about taking people's money away and
certainly not for very good reason I
mean if people don't engage and expect
to be supported and not do anything to
look for work then that's a particular
scenario but most people are far from
that particular situation but I think it
is true that there are some within those
various groups that we can help if we
come up with the the right policies to
do that and that's what I think we
should do and we know that of that 9
million 1.7 million are saying that they
want to work
so not everybody there will some
long-term people with long-term
illnesses where it just won't be
appropriate and it won't work and I
accept that but there are millions there
are some Millions for whom work is
actually going to be quite appealing if
we just make it happen
uh now the it it looks from reporting so
the pensions triple lock may be
protected you know the government's
talked a lot about people with the
broader shoulders at bearing at some of
the burden we're expecting to see a
squeeze in pay if you like for public
sector workers
um is it fair that for a retiree many of
whom are wealthy or they're except of
course there is pension poverty that
they might see their pensions go up by
10 along with inflation when public
sector workers could only dream of that
kind of price okay well the first thing
is I I can't confirm or deny whether the
triple lock will stay unfortunately I
have to wait until tomorrow what the
chancellor has to say but in terms of
that 10 of course the up rating that
occurred last time around which was in
April of uh last year uh pegged on the
previous September's inflation rate was
just 3.1 so there's an inflation was
running higher over most of the period
after that so there's an element of
swings and round events but I think the
critical thing about pensioners is that
unlike most of the rest of us there is a
time of life where re-engaging with
Workforce is much more problematic and
difficult and therefore it's much harder
for them to adjust their own economic
situation a public sector
as well if someone could click their
fingers and get a pay rise indeed indeed
so that that's why um the government has
come forward with all these
interventions like for example my
department has been sending eight
million households 60 650 pounds now
they are households typically on UC uh
they're the lowest income households in
the country and then there's 150 pounds
for those with disabilities 300 pounds
for pensioners again
um and uh help with council tax for
those on the lower council tax ban so
there's lots of targeted support that's
going into looking after just the people
that you're referring to okay um I want
to talk to you about Dominic Robb he of
course is facing an investigation into
allegations of bullying and behavior
is it correct that Richie sunac will be
the ultimate Arbiter of that
investigation and all the findings will
be passed to him to make a judgment my
understanding and I think Dominic has
done exactly the right thing there have
been a couple instances of complaints
that have come forward he's gone to the
Prime Minister he's recommended to the
Prime Minister that he looks into this
the pm has agreed when Lord guide is
replaced then there will be somebody to
look into that and I have no doubt that
that individual whoever it is will do so
without fear and favor so it won't be an
Ethics advisor sacked by Boris Johnson
well quite useful to have around the the
prime well the Prime Minister has made
it very clear the the that integrity and
transparency and good governance is
absolutely core to this government's
Mission so I have no doubt whoever
replaces Lord guide conducts this
investigation will do so without fear
favor or indeed interference so I'm
absolutely confident it will be
confident that it will be an independent
uh exercise
um just finally I want to talk a little
bit about the wider culture in
Westminster so you can park the
allegations about Dominic Robb for now
and you know our reporters Liz Bates and
Aggie Schoenberg have been investigating
a bullying in Westminster for a podcast
or Open Secret all parties not just the
conservatives and I just want to read to
you some of the anonymous quotes given
to them
she was always asking me the MP from
Mustafa she was always asking me to do
things that were inappropriate she got
me to scrub stains out the carpet
another one I remember feeling like a
dog in an rspca advert where they hide
behind the sofa when the owners are
coming back and finally I knew she had a
terrible reputation some other MPS
approached me after I left and said oh
my God how did you last that long right
well clearly we don't know the specifics
of all those cases that you've raised
but they sound pretty horrific and
they're unacceptable and that's why I
think the House of Commons as an in
general sort of umbrella to all the MPS
as employers has come a long way
actually with its grievance procedures
and people are encouraged to come
forward now so I think that's the way
forward but it's very sad when you hear
those things I totally agree I can only
speak from my own experience mixing and
mingling with members of parliament okay
I don't spend a lot of time down in the
bars as it happens and perhaps that's
where all the bad behavior goes on but I
found generally speaking that colleagues
are serious people who want to do the
best for their constituency and I say
that right across the house all parties
and generally treat their staff with
great respect but whether exceptions it
needs to be dealt with and I think the
processes are now there for that to
happen Okay thank you very much thank
you